so sorry what about those that do ask
for a reason they're denied yeah if they
if they ask for a raise and they're
denied they probably don't have the
skills but it's not it's not because
you're a woman you have to remember you
take into account that as a business
owner you're not trying to you want to
grow your business and scale your
business so in a capitalist Society you
pick the best to do the best job that
means man or woman so if you have a
woman in a job that asks for more money
and she's good at her job the likelihood
is going to give her that job I mean
give it give it a higher rate what
people what people fail to understand is
that there's characteristics that are
involved so women are actually more
agreeable than men are so men are so
even if we're supposed women are more
agreeable than men so me me and a woman
can be doing the exact same job I could
be doing less of that job but I demand
more but she's happy to accept that job
before it is so I'm going to excel
faster financially than she will the